what's going on guys my name is David
Tommy and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about the samsung s
20 ultra and comparing it to the top of
the line I phoned 11 pro max we're also
going to be announcing the giveaway went
up from a few videos back so stay tuned
for that the reason I selected these two
phones for a comparison today is because
they're both premium flagships from
premier manufacturers they are also
nearly identically priced right now in
April 2020 so in Australia you can pick
up the samsung s 20 old truck for $19.99
which is approximately equivalent to
twelve hundred and seventy USD you can
also pick up the iPhone 11 Pro max for
$18.99 or 1200 USD I know there's USD
figures it might be a little bit off but
that's because the Australian dollar has
dropped so much because of this Koba
dines name pandemic the best place to
always start with a tech comparison is
with a quick spec sheet now the spec
sheet doesn't really give us too much
until we start looking into it a little
bit more detail but we'll get into that
I'm gonna go through and let you know
all of the features for the S 20 and the
iPhone 11 side-by-side because again
many of you have asked for this feature
in the comments down below so I'm trying
to do everything I can to improve these
videos and make sure you continue
watching them and like them along the
way
so the s20 ultra comes in with a six
point nine inch display and the iPhone
11 has a 6.5 inch display
very minor differences but enough to be
significant I know personally I use the
s20 ultra every single day it is the
phone recording this video as well and
it is slightly ever so slightly a little
bit too big for my hands so in
preference I would actually prefer a 6.5
inch display like the iPhone 11 Pro Max
has on the back which is one of the most
important features of both phones is a
quarter camera set up on the s20
and a triple lens setup on the iPhone 11
pro max on the s20 ultra you get a
variety of different lenses and
megapixel counts you of course have the
main one hundred and eight megapixel
wide camera the 48 megapixel telephoto
camera and the 12 megapixel ultra wide
camera you also get the time-of-flight
camera which is considered their fourth
camera and all that is really is a very
advanced depth of field sensor which
Judas and bolts and some software bugs
you're probably going to notice along in
this video there is a very hard hunting
of focus throughout the whole video and
the s20 has some software bugs even with
- I think maybe three updates since I've
purchased this device all focused on the
camera they're still not perfect when
filming in 4k the iPhone 11 pro max on
the other hand has a triple ultra wide
normal and telephoto all at 12
megapixels on paper they are miles apart
the s20 ultra looks significantly better
but because of some software features
the iPhone is actually able to keep up
and we'll take a look at that very
shortly continuing on with the camera
and one of the most impressive features
that the s20 ultra has is its space zoom
capabilities now if you've seen the
results of this space zoom you know it's
a little bit potato especially when you
go to the maximum but I think it's more
about the potential of the technology
than anything else
the s20 ultra has a ten times optical
zoom which is able to extend it to a
hundred times due to zoom so everything
up to about thirty times zoom in my
experience is still pretty good and
still pretty clear when you go into a
hundred times room you get a little bit
of distortion a little bit of noise and
a little bit of pixelation so it isn't
perfect whereas the iPhone 11 Pro max
gives you that two times optical zoom
and a ten times digital zoom I do want
to showcase one photo here before we
dive into the
all photo review a little bit later on
this is a photo of the super moon that
happened a few weeks ago I was standing
in the middle of the park at nighttime
and you can actually see how far away I
am from it in the ultra white
perspective however I had to place this
phone up on I know it was a bowler to be
able to keep it steady at a hundred time
zone to actually be able to take a photo
because the camera itself shakes and
moves so much especially considering it
was a windy day but the final picture
produced wasn't actually half bad at all
to be able to get some detail and some
shadows in the moon itself from a phone
is very impressive to me so I just
wanted to follow up with that before we
move on to the next thing when we look
at the video specs the s20 ultra can
film an 8k at 24 frames a second that's
it absolute maximum it obviously does 4k
in 60 frames and 30 frames as well as
everything below the iPhone 11 Pro max
tops out at 4k 60 frames per second even
though the s20 ultra does have a KP
recording I personally haven't found it
to be a high enough quality to actually
use in an everyday situation so I always
stick to the 4k 30 frames a second on
this device when we compare the
performance the s20 Ultra comes out on
top on paper but in reality it is a
different story the s20 ultra has 5g
capabilities which no doesn't call Skoda
19 so stop googling that it also has 12
to 16 gigabytes of RAM 128 gigs to 512
gigs of storage and up to one terabyte
of microSD storage Caird with 120 Hertz
refresh rate screen five thousand
milliamp hours battery the Snapdragon
805 processor it isn't beast on paper
the iPhone 11 has an a 13 Bionic chip 4
gigabytes of RAM only and option
64 128 and 512 megabytes of storage it
has no potential for expandable storage
and only 3969 million hours of battery
inside when you compare those facts on
the paper you think wow the s20 ultra
has got it beat but when you put it into
reality and actually take a look at the
software driving the hardware and look
at it from a geek bench performance
rating well the s20 ultra versus the
iPhone 11 Pro max is a very different
story on geek bench for example the s20
ultra gives a single core reading 891
whilst the iPhone tops that with 1336
the multi-core rating is again the same
thing 3205 for the s20 ultra and 3237
for the iphone 11 Pro max so the iPhone
is able even with its four gigs of ram
to top out the performance of the s20
ultra because the software on apple's
devices are so thin dur down
minimalistic and optimized perfectly to
be able to perform way better than s 20
ultra ok so let's move on to the photo
comparison I've taken a few of these
photos from Tom's guide because he has
done an exceptional job at comparing
them but I want to compare them in my
own perspective and light the night mode
photo is one of the most I believe
perfect photos I guess to compare these
through devices
it puts actual hardware and actual
software to the test now in Tom's guide
he said that actually the iPhone 11 is a
better quality photo in this example but
personally I don't believe that at all
if you take a look at the s20 ultras
color quality cleanest and sharpness you
can definitely tell that the software is
able to override what Apple is able to
produce in these low light situations it
is also able to produce a much more
natural-looking photo whereas the iPhone
11 gives it more of a warmer tone
personally for me
makes it a little bit easier to edit in
post especially in library I found that
every further I've taken in her GIC
format of the s20 ultra has been
phenomenal and very very easy to edit in
library which going from raw to agic is
actually a very nice surprise
the only issue here is when the focus is
good on the s20 culture the focus is
still a software glitch and there is so
many times is hunting for focus it
doesn't have dual pixel autofocus so
you're tapping on the screen trying to
make it focus and it's missing the point
entirely but most the time it is pretty
good it does a decent enough job however
it does definitely draw this phone down
when you're spending $2,000 on a phone
and having focus problems okay so we're
about halfway through the video I
thought I'd take a short break to
announce the winner of the giveaway if
you didn't know already in a couple
years ago I was giving away the Samsung
Galaxy buds plus to a lucky winner now I
have absolutely no idea how to do this
so I generated a random number using
Google random number generator and
decided to count down the comments
because I actually don't know how to do
any differently if you do let me know in
the comments down below this is my first
giveaway so the lucky winner is number
61 and it is Mary Matthews so Mary
please send me a damn on Instagram
Twitter whatever you want and get in
touch so I can send these butts to you
as soon as possible continuing with the
performance now and as we know the
iPhone 11 Pro max has actually
outperformed the s20 ultra with
Geekbench results but what does that
mean in a real life comparison when
gaming for example I'm not a big phone
game and personally don't have a time
for it all the patients so I just tested
these in a very simple scenario for me
the 120 Hertz refresh rate and the
biggie of really an hour battery
allows me to actually enjoy the games a
little bit longer and enjoy the
performance a little bit better so
having a hundred twenty Hertz refresh
rate versus the standard iPhone eleven
sixty Hertz refresh rate is a pretty big
difference for me even though it will
perform better on the iPhone 11 overall
I think it is a very difficult decision
to make if you're going out and
purchasing one of these phones yes 20
ultra has a plethora of amazing details
and huge numbers that are overwhelming
whilst the iPhone 11 pro max has a track
record of phenomenal performance great
customer service great history for me I
own an s2000 truck is my device of
choice that is because I like to have
some freedom in my performance and in my
software that is the only reason but if
I was to take away that fanboy nature
from Samsung and actually look at this
in a realistic light I think I would
wait three months to purchase the s20
ultra for them to really work out all
the bugs especially these focusing ones
I do apologize if my face goes in and
out of focus many a time during this
video if I had to purchase one now
knowing all these facts I would have
probably purchased die phone 11 Pro max
so that is a very simple comparison for
me today guys I hope you enjoyed the
content unlike usual I am going to be
back very very shortly over this
quarantine period I'm gonna try produce
as much content as I can for you guys so
stay tuned smash that subscribe button
20:20 style and I'll see you in just a
couple of days